so it's the fun you you bring your hands
up begin to concentrate coalescing the
arcane energy into the strange dome
below of greening your hands as the
swirl continues to spiral you shoot your
hands forward releasing this burst of
corrosive energy towards the fetus it's
been a while since you've used this
explosive power in this town in your
eagerness you weren't paying attention
to your target the arrow arcs to the
side missing your target instead
striking kalim in the back of the
shoulders no not Kelly I'm sorry Kelly
try to help what are you doing new and
even trying to put him out of his misery
you manage to pierce him with the rapier
cuz he's not moving but you don't reach
any vital organs so now you're just
adding more pain to his slowly sizzling
misery Kelly comes finally you have no
idea what this building is is this even
a building what is this as you shout
that out that's tough on you turn around
and look up and immediately see a sign
hanging over the door that says uh
butcher oh how did you not notice that
Cinderella
what knows what look at the sign right
there
what's on it says butcher now it doesn't
Jesus Christ door clicks and opens up
into a dark interior you have that light
smell still I already used it can I
can't be bothered to do anything
light spell you can do an infinite
number of times yeah I know okay how's
your light spill in rainbow color okay a
very beautiful very beautiful array of
rainbow color streaks across the room
you can now see indeed this is a butcher
shop there is a large a fabulous
magician dead unicorns everywhere okay
where's the boys the blood goin this is
the part where I say let's just go back
okay can I cast a rainbow spell to make
the situation a little nicer you can you
cast your right spell an array of
beautiful colors lighting up the tunnels
you guys not so quietly turned the
corner with this vibrant bright rainbow
light expelling from the front of
Stefan's quarter staff the large figure
pulls its hood back and you can see what
looks like a snarling ogre face standing
about 12 to 13 feet tall its head is
bulbous and mutated like some sort of
pulsating creature has taken root on the
right side of its face its eyes beeline
unnatural intelligence for its kind you
dare interrupt our sacred gifting
ceremony I will know your names in
intent so we might whisper them to the
silence screamer and crush your memory
on this world and with that we will
leave this game on a cliffhanger Don
tanta oh can we lose Killeen